Speaker 1: Let's go next to.
How about Stevie from Asheville, North Carolina?
Stevie, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hey, David.
Thanks for having me on.
My pleasure.
I just had a question, a little bit of a specific
question today.
I guess the theme is Supreme Court.
But so in the idea of or in counseling, there's
this concept of duty to protect, whereas a
client has confidentiality from their therapist
in most cases, except for a few specific ones,
and just take to list one.
For instance, child abuse.
If a client were to disclose to a therapist
that they're abusing their child, then duty
to war and duty to protect the counselor would
have to inform the law.
Of course, my question is, in the wake of
some of this, in the wake of the Supreme Court
decision in which some states are going to
ban abortion, I'm curious if some states are
going to say, oh, a fetus that is a child,
if a if a client were to say they're seeking
an abortion outside of the state, does would
that fall under child abuse?
And would the counselor have a duty to protect
for an unborn child?
Speaker 1: So they would absolutely argue
that.
I think the question would be whether local
police could really do anything about it,
because let's imagine a different example,
I guess imagine that a client disclosed to
a client in Texas, disclose to their therapist,
I'm planning to kill someone in Amsterdam
or something like that.
Okay.
So the therapist can go and they can call
Texas police and Texas police maybe could
ask some questions, but they really probably
can't do anything.
The crime is supposedly going to happen in
Amsterdam.
And then if you call Amsterdam police and
say this person might be doing this thing,
they would say, okay, thanks for letting us
know if they come to Amsterdam, then we will
be aware of it.
But there's nothing they can do until the
person is there.
So indeed, in thinking about the instance
of, Oh, abortion's banned in Texas, you tell
your therapist I'm going to go to neighboring
wherever to get an abortion.
I don't think Texas police can really do anything
about it because it's not a crime in that
other state and they're not planning to do
it in Texas.
Yeah, I think that they will make the argument,
but I don't think it will be very effective
at doing anything.
Speaker 5: Right.
I think that it all comes back to trying to
enforce abortion laws like this in general
is just kind of silly.
Speaker 1: Yes, it is.
It absolutely is.
And there are going to be all sorts of absurd
situations like this, for sure.
But we'll have to deal with them as they come
up.
Speaker 5: Right.
Okay, well, that.
That's just the thought I've been having lately.
Thank you for having me on.
Speaker 1: All right.
Steve from Asheville, very much appreciate
it.
Nice connection.
Got right to the question.
Hard to beat that.